aquí tenemos la cantidad de volumen de
un líquido en términos de galones un
galón y dos galones y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es convertir este
volumen de un líquido que tenemos aquí
en galones a las otras unidades usuales
que se manejan para volumen de líquidos
en eeuu por lo pronto te invito a que
pongas pausa en el vídeo y trates de
convertir un galón en cuartos pintas
tasas y onzas líquidas bien un galón es
igual a cuatro cuartos así es que
tenemos que multiplicar por cuatro para
obtener uno por cuatro cuatro cuartos
cada cuarto es igual a dos pintas así es
que si cada cuarto tiene dos pintas
cuatro cuartos va a tener cuatro por 28
pintas ahora cada pinta tiene dos tazas
por lo cual 8 tenemos que multiplicarlo
por 2 para obtener 16 tazas finalmente
cada taza contiene 8 onzas líquidas así
es que aquí tenemos que multiplicar por
8 por lo cual 16 tazas contienen 16 por
8 8 por 6 40
llevamos 48 x 18 4 128 onzas líquidas
ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo con 2
galones vamos a convertir los cuartos
pintas tazas y onzas fluidas y de nueva
cuenta te invito a que le pongas pausa
al vídeo para que lo intentes solo bien
es exactamente el mismo procedimiento si
un galón equivale a 4 cuartos 2 galones
equivalen a 2 por 48 cuartos
cada cuarto equivale a dos pintas ocho
cuartos equivalen a ocho por 216 pintas
cada pinta equivale a dos tazas
dieciséis pintas equivalen a 16 por 232
tazas finalmente cada taza equivale a 8
onzas líquidas 32 tazas equivalen a
vamos a ver 32 por 8 256 onzas líquidas
y observa lo siguiente cuando vamos de
un galón a 2 cuando estamos duplicando
el volumen en galones también estamos
duplicando el volumen en cuartos vamos
de 4 a 8
también estamos duplicando el volumen en
pintas vamos de 8 a 16 lo duplicamos en
tazas de 16 a 32 y también en otras
líquidas de 128 a 256 básicamente al
incrementar el volumen en galones por un
factor de 2 sin importar en qué unidad
vas a expresar el volumen este se va a
incrementar también por un factor de 2